que cette suppression pourrait être de
nature à augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
des consommateurs
pour jean-marc jancovici ingénieur
spécialiste des énergies et bien c'est
une honte l'idée de déréguler un
monopoly énergétiques naturelles emi a
déjà joué avec l'électricité et le
premier résultats qu'on a obtenus c'est
pas du tout d'obtenir une baisse des
tarifs c'est d'obtenir une hausse des
tarifs dans le coma on a quand même un
peu la mémoire courte
e ap tel point que bon nombre
d'industriels après avoir plaidé pour
un système dérégulé ce sont il
médiatement mi a plaidé pour un retour
dans le système régulé et on a
inventé son logement au nigéria
cependant pas de faire on n'attendait